hey everybody
um welcome to my talk about build packs
on google cloud
my name is matt saldo i am a product
manager at google
focusing on our serverless compute
platforms cloud run
app engine and cloud functions and for
the past few months i've been working on
bringing
google cloud's build packs to market and
i'm really excited about talking
uh to you about them today so
what we'll be covering in this talk
first of all we'll go over what build
packs are
we'll talk about why you might want to
use build packs and
finally we'll look at uh build pack
support on google cloud
how to use build packs on google cloud
and we'll do a nice demo
uh tying a few of our products together
using buildpacks
so just in case you don't want to sit
through the entire presentation let's do
a tldr
so buildpacks create containers without
using a docker file
you just give the build pack your source
code and the build pack detects what
language you're using
and creates a runnable container that
you can run locally with docker
or we could run on the kubernetes
platform or anywhere else
so let's just take a look at that in
action uh on my laptop right now
okay so to use buildpacks we use the
pack command that
is the reference implementation of
a buildpack platform and you can see the
uh
available uh commands unpack here and
we're just gonna use the most basic one
which is
pack build by default it builds the
current directory and we're in
uh the you can see this java maven
directory here and you just need to
provide the name of the container image
that you're
creating and we'll call this hello
buildpacker and
so you can see it went through detection
phase
where it found um a few build packs a
java runtime java maven and java entry
point
uh it did some analysis and
it is now building this application
you can see it's using the google java
runtime
build pack and using java 11
that's specified by our definition
the google build packs definition of
what to do when it
finds a java app and it is now
finishing up its build and it has
successfully done and created this hello
build packer image so now i can just run
that
and we'll bind it to port 80 so we can
load it in our web browser this is a
server that i have
up in gce and that was hello bill packer
and it runs and there we go
it started and now we go over to our web
browser this is the address of my server
it wasn't working before but if i do a
reload
boom hello buildpacker it works and so
you can see in just
a couple of seconds we built a java app
and got it running running
in a docker container and that is
uh a quick demo of build packs
so that was built packs in action now
build packs allow you to take advantage
of the benefits of containers without
needing to understand them
so you can isolate your code you can
create microservices architectures you
can run on
orchestration platforms like kubernetes
without needing to write docker files or
understand the inner organs of docker
so super cool now recently google cloud
uh released a set of open source build
packs you can find them on github at the
address that you see in this screenshot
google cloud platform slash build packs
and these cover
a bunch of the most popular languages go
javascript
java php python
and ruby and they are
designed to create secure container
images which can run
on any of the runtimes from google cloud
such as cloud run gke or anthos
and of course because they're open
source you're able to fork them and use
them
however you'd like now even though
they're relatively new
these build packs have powered over 10
million
builds in production and that's because
they started off as an implementation
detail
for app engine and uh google cloud
functions
and they've been uh powering
all of these source builds on those two
products uh for a while now
so we're pretty confident in their
robustness
and you can use them confidently too in
production
but in addition to app engine cloud
functions google cloud
build packs are available on many of our
products uh their support for them in
cloud build cloud run
cloud shell cloud code and scaffold
and we'll dive into the specifics of
that later on
so that was the overview let's dive in
what are build packs exactly uh they are
a cncf sandbox project those are newer
projects
in the uh cloud native uh project and
you can find them at buildpacks.io
uh there are several uh large companies
contributing to the project
in addition to google um pivotal cloud
foundry
is a major backer as is salesforce uh
via the heroku division
and like we said before build packs take
your source code and they
create a container but there's a little
more to them than this and let's take a
look
at that build packs actually
run in a container themselves called a
builder
so here you can see in a little more
detail
that uh a a container called the builder
runs the build packs um and you can see
there's actually two scripts they run
the first one is a detect script and
that detects what language
your code is and um the the detection
it's actually not a rocket science it's
an ordered list
of um tests and the first test that
comes back positive
uh is declared the language so these
tests can be very simple
like is there a packages.json and if
that's true then it's a javascript
application and you can of course
override those but you'll find that
they're
they usually work just fine and then
after the detection script happens
a build step happens that actually does
the building
so the builder it's itself an oci image
um it contains all the build packs and
groups and binaries needed to do the
building
and it runs on a platform uh and that
could be as simple as the pax cli
command that you saw in the demo
or something like cloud builder techton
and that actually
runs the uh the image and you can see
here a little cli snapshot
the pac command if you uh invoke suggest
builders
it'll show you some of the builders that
are uh known to it
um and you know google's one of those uh
this is also showing picado which are
the
that's the branding of the build packs
uh from pivotal that were released
recently they're also very good
and just to add another layer um there's
also a thing called a build pack group
uh build packs themselves are very small
units of execution they can be designed
to do just one thing like run an npm
install you know just installing
dependencies
and a build pack group is a collection
of those and that lets you reuse
smaller bits of code um like doing a
dependency install
and then and use those across different
build pack groups so
when most people say build pack they're
actually talking about the build pack
group that does the full build
um but it's uh it depends how the build
packs are actually designed
finally there is another piece of the
build pack called the stack
and this is the base image or base layer
that your application code is put on top
of here we
show an ubuntu stack which is what
google cloud's built packs use
and they can contain some system
libraries
on top of that base layer and then your
application code and dependencies
get put at the at the top of that layer
stack
um build packs cannot do an apt-get to
install dependencies
uh so those need to be part of the stack
and we have designed the stacks for the
cloud build packs
to contain the most common things that
you likely need
so you shouldn't have to redefine that
if you're using them yourself
so string all of that together we can
see here
a flow diagram where the source code
gets taken into the builder image uh
the build packs and build pack groups
run on it they run the detect script to
figure out which language it is
they run the build script uh they
install all of your
dependencies your source code whether
it's compiled or just direct goes on top
of there
and that gets layered on top of the
stack and
and then uh that layer cake that you see
on the right
the green and the gray uh that forms the
complete
container image which you can then run
wherever you'd like
so that's a pretty detailed look into
how the build pack works
so why would you actually want to use
these things
well for starters a recent study
found that 44 of containers in the wild
had known vulnerabilities for which
patches existed
this just shows that writing your own
docker file it can actually be quite
fraught with errors
unless you're an expert or maybe have a
platform team that
provides stalker files for you so using
build packs
lets you circumvent that danger uh uh
assuming the build packs are designed
with security in mind
um now uh google cloud build packs
are just that they've been security
audited and they're constantly updated
uh making sure that they will not
produce uh vulnerabilities or certainly
at the bottom layer of the stack the
base layer uh doesn't have any uh
security issues that we're aware of
uh the containers are built according to
um our container best practices
uh call that the google way uh as much
as we can via the
via build packs um and uh
all these things let you like container
novices uh deploy to container platforms
like kubernetes uh without needing to
write their own docker files um and you
know even if your organization
um is uh has adopted docker maybe that
that adoption is not even and there are
some teams
that uh haven't yet adopted it but they
could take advantage of centralized
platforms for running their code
another use for build packs even if you
do know daca really well is if you just
need to do a quick and easy build maybe
you're
checking out an open source project or
some code
that you don't expect to be using long
term and you don't want to write a
docker file from scratch for it
so just use a build pack uh build it try
it out
and then boom you're done some specific
google cloud use cases
uh for uh build packs um because we're
using build packs to power the builds on
app engine or cloud functions
uh if you wanna migrate away from those
platforms to one of our others like
cloud run
or gke you can take those app engine and
cloud function build packs
uh you could continue to run them
against your source code
and have the same build process
happening
on your new platform and as you know
when you're migrating keeping as many
things constant
as possible is very very helpful to
minimize the disruption from that
migration
finally another reason to use build
packs
is because they are so well integrated
into so many parts of google cloud
like cloud build that um you can sort of
reuse that
the knowledge and those tools um across
many parts
of your cloud platform so now let's take
a look at
the support for build packs on google
cloud first of all
uh we already went over the open source
build packs um you are free to
fork those um modify them however you
like
uh it's quite easy to do and in the
readme
you'll find uh documentation how to do
that um cloud build
um which is our builder as a service
uh now has native support for build
packs um so
if you have source code and want it
built instead of running
build packs locally you can just uh push
that to cloud build and we'll build it
for you
uh at the moment uh that uh support is
cli only
uh but uh support in the console uh will
be coming soon
uh cloud run our next generation
serverless platform
uh supports direct source deployments
with buildpacks
so you can just do a cloud run deploy
push your source code
and it will build and deploy that all in
one step
uh you can also set up continuous
integration
with both cloud build and cloud run
where every time you update
your source repository it will do
a fresh build of that source using
buildplex
build packs and deploy to cloud run uh
cloud shell which you can access the
cloud console already has the uh build
pack tool
pack pre-installed so you don't need to
do that if you are using our shell
uh like we talked about already app
engine and cloud functions uh both
uh are building with build packs already
um and finally uh cloud code
uh lets you deploy to cloud run or gke
uh using build packs as the build
mechanism and it actually does
that via scaffold which also now has
native support
for build packs so a really broad swath
of support for build packs across cloud
which is really pretty exciting
and now let's take a look at that in
action
and i will show you a soup to nuts uh
build and deployment using buildpacks on
google cloud
let's take a look at how to use
buildpacks with google cloud
so i'm back in my terminal and i have a
a pretty simple uh go app right here
a little different from the one we were
looking at before and if we just take a
look
at the main html file you can see it's a
pretty
boilerplate uh app and all it does
once you get past all that css is just
pull some environment
variables uh from the request and
says hello to you and displays those so
let's build it
but let's start by assuming we actually
haven't installed the pac command and
just do the entire build in the cloud
so i'm going to use the gcloud build
submit
and i'm just going to give it the pack
flag to tell it to
uh build this with a build pack and then
i'm going to pass along
the name of the image uh and the full
container registry address that i wanted
to want to use so i'm just going to call
this one run
so we do that and we can see it is
creating a tarball and uploading my app
into google cloud in a storage bucket
and then it is going to initiate that
build pack
and you can see right here it is pulling
down uh the builder
these are the docker layers being pulled
down
and um it's already cached so it should
be pretty fast
and so now it's running the detection
phase of the build pack that's where it
decides what language it is and it
should show us that yep it is using go
and
then it does the build it's going to
compile my go code
using go 114 and
it is doing that now looks like it just
finished
and now it's going to create my final
docker image uh putting my application
code
on top of the stack so it's doing that
and it looks like it is now putting the
completed image
into my container registry and that is
all done
so now that we have a built
container image let's deploy it
so to deploy it i'm going to use cloud
run that is google's
next generation serverless container
engine
and i'm just going to tell it to
deploy a new service to cloud run and
using that image that we
uh just created from cloud build
so i fire this up and it's going to ask
me a few questions i'm going to choose
our fully managed
cloud run platform you can of course
also
use um cloudrunforanthos
if you uh have installed that on top of
your anthos cluster
i haven't so i'm just going to choose
the fully managed option
and i'm going to call this my demo
run for
screencast service
that should be unique and i'll choose
the region let's go us central
and allow unauthenticated just to make
this more interesting
let's um just make this a private
service
that uh you need to be authenticated to
use so
i'm doing that and now it is deploying
the service
and um cloud run services have revisions
uh this will be the first revision
and now it's routing traffic to it so
we're all done
and it gives me this url right here
which i can use
to access the service and i
am going to hit that up i'm just going
to use the curl command right here so we
stay right in the terminal
and here's my command i'm curling that
same url
and you can see i'm adding a header with
an authorization field and then i'm
going to call the gcloud command again
to give it my identity token so i do
that
and it's firing it up and boom it
we get a bunch of html back that is that
container
you can see if i do that same thing but
don't pass
the authorization token
then i get a forbidden
error because i haven't authenticated
properly so
there you just saw us building
some application code um in using our
service cloud build with its
brand new native build pack integration
and then it stored that
in the container registry and then we
created a brand new cloud run service um
that was uh protected via
authentication and that all took just a
couple minutes
and that is one of the easiest ways i
know to
build a new service and deploy it to the
cloud securely
thanks very much so that was build packs
in action on google cloud
um so in this talk we have explained
what build packs are
why you want to use them and how to use
them on google cloud
i hope you enjoyed it and i hope you'll
try build packs
out soon thanks very much and have a
great day
you